kill this kill this one before they call
others talk okay if it isn't the won't
come how did I get [ __ ] are you
listening from now on when I talk pay
attention I've left marks on your
pip-boy find the three of the callers in
town 8 12 and 14 get them to the
fountain obey me and you can all go free
remember you you were mean to dog make
dog it
why used dog
hope the voice doesn't come back bad ya
got okay okay we got dogs so dogs a lot
better because he eats the bodies it'll
come back out okay look s bets right
here I said you you [ __ ] got deck
right get your dick sucked ain't gonna
yeah did I thought your that's his
golfing whiskey I'll take it uh-huh
what what is that
dicey some weird solid something bad
tastes like burnt wires okay here you go
you return you got always yell at dawg
the other dog because gets hungry can't
stop always need more pack and vet hum
yeah yeah a de pecho
not good okay you know I'm glad that's
happening oh that's in here bunch of
[ __ ] I think they say yeah mass just
taps baby voice doesn't come back bad it
sounded so I go in there how I
inside scrub how do I the [ __ ] is that
have a fine [ __ ] leave the Salida del
Sol gate alone you're not done with the
Vilia so don't stress ok suck and fast
where is master but did he go away dog
will be good this time yeah that sounds
money right here then what the [ __ ]
okay got get got there we go here we go
picking up signals near your location
detonators watch for traps ouch
[ __ ] I need some [ __ ] ate [ __ ] that's
it how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do this
then
food
how is it unconsciously there's no
[ __ ] it can't see that what the [ __ ]
was that
yeah it goes explode now ow ow ow was at
hand
do I have don't like this place won't
you go back oh [ __ ] this actually gonna
hard this place back to the base
just followed something bad taste like
burnt wires
is there like how the [ __ ] do I continue
further
always yelling dog the other dog because
gets hungry you can't stop it always me
for chases let the flying [ __ ]
it says there's an entrance don't like
this place want to go back back after
days hello what's that over there there
we go she says okay so I have any aid
okay okay
okay i get i got it
always yelling dog got a dog because
gets home type oh yeah [ __ ] problem
that of time to wonder if you're gonna
be a [ __ ] problem your dream was free
the way to us keep rolling in Yeah right
oh [ __ ] do I get up there oh good all
the way around can I see these chips so
um your duty was free the way tourists
keep rolling in
Oh paid fit yes yes besides while then
tourist is hurrying a novelty factor
that her teen Dharma now have a seat and
then we'll talk [ __ ] psycho bad
the sierra madre beauty isn't she she
the one who invited or maybe you didn't
catch her voice by the way don't get a
polemic innocent great or more on get up
without my permission I'll blast your s
so far for you sir and just because I I
heard my necktie beeping I know what
that means it left us a cursed I hearted
and if you put me in it I'm not going to
be too good good then we're in business
if you're here you want to live I want
what's in the month